on s'arrête sur l'une des conséquences
de cette guerre de nombreuses banques
russes sont exclues de la plateforme
inter bancaire swift c'était l'une des
principales demandes de kiev l2
occidentaux ont décidé d'amplifier leurs
sanctions déjà vaste contre là aussi
l'objectif étant d'étouffer
financièrement les russes en quoi
consiste ce réseau swift nous retrouvons
à bruxelles laxmi lota bonjour laxmi les
européens ont fini par franchir ce cap
en coupant une partie des banques russes
de ce réseau
oui la plateforme suif est un système
qui permet les échanges bancaires
internationaux cette sanction couper un
pays du réseau swift est souvent
qualifié d' armes nucléaires économique
dans les conséquences pour le pays
concernés sont importantes alors
plusieurs pays européens étaient
réticents à cette mesure l'allemagne par
exemple qui craignait de ne plus pouvoir
payer les livraisons de gaz russe mais
cette mesure est ici cible est limitée
seules quelques banques russes sont
concernés d'ailleurs le ministre
allemand de l'économie indique nous
travaillons en ce moment pour limiter
les dommages collatéraux de cette
déconnexion à suivre cette mesure
devrait entrer en vigueur dans les
prochains jours
les etats unis le canada et le royaume
uni vont aussi appliquer cette mesure
par ailleurs bruxelles annonce aussi une
mesure pour toucher cette fois à la
banque centrale russe objectif limiter
fortement la capes la capacité russe de
financer cette guerre en ukraine laxmi
les ministres des affaires étrangères
des vingt-sept vont se réunir ce
dimanche à quel type de décision peut-on
s'attendre alors ce sont les ministres
de l'intérieur de l'union européenne qui
vont se réunir en urgence à partir de 13
heures cet après midi heure de bruxelles
ils vont parler d'eux la gestion de
l'aide humanitaire envoyée à l'ukraine
de l'accueil des réfugiés également de
la protection de la sécurité des
frontières extérieures selon
l'organisation des nations unies cent
cinquante mille personnes ont déjà fui
l'ukraine la crise pourrait provoquer le
déplacement de 5 millions de réfugiés
les pays membres de l'ue eux se sont
déjà dits prêts à les aider pour
l'instant l'aide se concentrent vers les
pays en première ligne ceux qui
reçoivent ces réfugiés à savoir la
pologne mais également dans une moindre
mesure pour l'instant la hongrie la
roumanie et la slovaquie l'allemagne
s'est déjà dit prête à aider massivement
ses voisins laxmi l'hôte à bruxelles